bien
même si je n'ai pas tout compris on va
essayer de trouver un temps un peu plus
apaisé
mesdames les présidentes
mes chers collègues nous vous
accueillons chers collègues également
dans notre hémicycle historique pour
fêter ensemble les 60 ans du traité de
l'Élysée qui a porté les bases d'une
coopération profonde entre deux pays
autrefois et demi aujourd'hui amis
mon parcours
pas mal
d'intervenants on parlait de leur
parcours mon parcours comme celui de
certaines de mes collègues de mon groupe
à l'instar de Sabine Tillet et Delphine
linman témoigne d'une certaine manière
de cette transformation profonde des
relations entre nos deux pays je suis
Nasser Burke en Allemagne en 1954 par
les hasards d'une affectation de mon
père militaire
en 1963 le président de Gaulle et le
chancelier Adenauer signé le traité de
l'Élysée sur l'amitié franco-allemande
force est de reconnaître que ce traité a
atteint ses objectifs
sur le rapprochement des peuples d'abord
et notamment des jeunes on en a beaucoup
parlé ce matin et je les vois ici dans
haut de cette émission
jeune de 22 ans alors responsable des
jeunes giscardiens génération sociale et
libérale en Béarn je me suis rendu à
l'invitation de nos amis de la Jungo
union avec plusieurs de mes camarades
donc à voyager dans le Berlin divisé
nous avions dormi dans les locaux de
l'ophage l'Office franco-allemand de la
jeunesse et je pu me rendre compte à
l'époque des contrastes du Berlin
d'alors une ambiance particulière de
guerre froide mais en même temps une
vitalité incroyable
je n'ai pas fait de rencontre amoureuse
mais j'aurais peut-être pu et ce voyage
et ce voyage
et ce voyage a beaucoup fait pour la
compréhension de l'Allemagne pour un
béarné d'adoption comme moi cette
coopération s'est amine tienne et pas
seulement culturelle elle infuse dans
l'ensemble des pans de la société je
suis élu d'un Sud-Ouest où le nom
d'Airbus est synonyme pour de nombreuses
PME et de TI de contrats et d'emplois et
mais aussi
mais surtout d'innovation et de fierté
nos deux économies sont toujours plus
intégrées et cela ne peut être qu'une
bonne nouvelle elle est aussi
signe de politique la relation
franco-allemande et depuis 60 ans moteur
de la construction européenne qui font
de l'engagement politique que nombre de
mes collègues démocrates je veux prendre
pour exemple plan de relance européen
qui explique que notre continent se
remet mieux la crise de la covid que ce
que nous craignons au printemps 2020
nous avions su ensemble apprendre de nos
erreurs de 2008 et impulser à de
nouvelles à deux une nouvelle dynamique
européenne la création de l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande en 2019
est aussi une nouvelle avancée si
auparavant les discussions étaient le
fait des pouvoirs exécutifs de part et
d'autre du Rhin nous nous réunissons
ensemble régulièrement notamment pour
tenir ses gouvernements comptables de
notre de cette relation et de rester
ensemble de une perspective pour notre
travail en commun il y a comme dans les
couples où toutes les familles parfois
des désaccords ou des rendez-vous
manqués c'est bien normal mais je crois
que la force de notre relation et que
nous savons que quelque soit ces
difficultés passagères nous nous
retrouverons toujours pour essayer
d'avancer ensemble le retour de la
guerre en Europe nous rappelle tant la
réussite historique représente cette
amitié que la nécessité de la préserver
et de la profondeur même au prix
d'efforts de chaque côté les démocrates
y prendront leur part je vous remercie
et vive l'amitié franco-allemande
[Applaudissements]